Daniel: Hello and welcome, everyone.
Welcome back.
This is the second interval of the third
applied active inference symposium at the
active inference institute on August 22,
2023.
This is going to be another packed and
exciting interval, and we're kicking it
off with Jean Francois Cloutier, a
Collective of theorizers First Steps.
So, JF, thank you for joining and to you
for this presentation.
And if anybody has questions for this
presentation or any of the others, please
just put it in the live chat and I'll do
it.
I can.
So thanks, JF.
To you.
JF: Thank you, Daniel.
I'm a software engineer at a company
called Smart Rent, where I write software
for smart home systems.
I also work on a research project at the
Active Inference Institute called the
Robotics and Embodied Project.
My current focus is unsupervised learning
in active inference agents.
In my presentation today, which is titled
A Collective of theorizers First Steps, I'
'll first start with a brief recap of the
project, then dive into recent progress,
and then I'll conclude with what I see as
the next steps of the project.
Well, since 2017, I've been experimenting
with Lego robots and models of cognition.
.
I do this for my own education, because,
like I think most of us, I understand
something better when I build it.
What you see here is my latest robot
model.
It's a rover.
It has a whole bunch of sensors and a
number of effectors actuators.
As a matter of fact, those sensors and
actuators can be understood as forming
the marker blanket of my robot.
Last year, I presented at the symposium
about the history of the project, its
then status, and its ambitions.
I presented a cognitive model that
implemented predictive processing from an
active inference perspective.
So there were generative models, there
was predictions, there was prediction
errors.
And these generative models animated the
robots so that they would roam, avoid
obstacles, observe their companion, and
also, in a very simplistic way, build a
theory of mind of the other robot.
They could from observations infer that
the other robot had detected food, food
being presented here as a sheet of paper
on the floor, and then would kind of try
to track the other robot to also get to
the food and fun stuff like this.
The implementation combined multi
processing and functional computing.
There was nothing probabilistic in the
implementation.
I thought maybe we'd see them in action.
That's what's presented last year.
But just to get a sense of what they do,
I have two robots here, one named Karl
and Andy.
I named them before I knew I was going to
present at the conference.
So they benefited from a number of
training sessions.
They learned how to find which policies
would achieve their goals better than
others.
And one here on the left.
Found the food rather right away but got
closer to the pedestal where the beacon
is that simulates the scent of food
feared was getting into a collision and
then backs off in a hurry as we'll see
the other robot observes all this, sees
the robot backing off as being in a panic
and decides to share this emotion and
backs up as well.
So fun stuff.
From the beginning I've implemented
different cognition models but they all
have in common the fact that they
implement a society of mind.
So what is a society of mind?
A society of mind is a concept by which
the mind is not a monolithic structure
but a composition of simple actors,
independent actors that interact with
each other in simple ways.
That view of the mind was put forth by
Marvin Minsky 50 years ago.
So this is not recent.
Again, what I presented last year was a
society of mind containing a hierarchy of,
, I call them cognition actors.
Each cognition actor is an independent
process, each one has a scope, a level of
abstraction as well.
So for example, you would have a
cognition actor that's concerned with the
location of food and it would have
beliefs and perceptions about food
location and these would feed into a
higher level cognition actor, let's say
food approach which is concerned about
getting closer to the food and so forth
and so on.
These cognition actors communicate again
in simple ways.
This is the society of mind and they
communicate by emitting predictions,
predictions about the beliefs of other
cognition actors and they communicate by
emitting prediction errors.
When predictions made about their beliefs
by others are inaccurate that leads to
connection actors processing these
prediction errors and combining them with
their own predictions to create an
updated set of perceptions that are
synthesized into beliefs.
And these beliefs lead to actions in
order to eliminate negative beliefs or
validate positive beliefs.
Now it's from the interactions of all
these kung fu actors that seemingly
purposeful behaviors emerge.
So that was successful but learning was
very limited.
This hierarchy of cognition actors was
given, was predefined and the only
learning that a robot would do was to
discover which action policies tended to
be more effective.
So clearly my robots are not monolithic
active inference agents.
So the question is why would I use a
society of mind architecture?
Well, because I subscribe to the notion
that all intelligence is collective
intelligence.
This paper makes the argument quite
cogently and I'm going to cite a number
of papers which were important to the
evolution of my thinking.
This is one of them.
This paper sees intelligence as a process,
, not a property.
It's a process enacted by the interacting
parts as opposed to again, a property of
individuals.
So society of mind is basically that it's
actually a number of interacting
processes that together from which emerge
apparently intelligent behaviors.
Now my own personal current definition of
intelligence is self sustaining, inactive
sense making.
Sense making is really important by
autonomous agent system in a dissipative
and dynamic environment and this guides
all the work I do in this project.
Now, if you want a description, a
detailed description of where my project
stood a year ago, there's a paper that
was published that I published on Xenodo,
which you can look up.
Now, over the last year, I wanted to move
away from a pre built a given society of
mind and toward a learned society of mind.
.
I wanted to see if I could program an
autonomous robot to evolve its society of
mind through its interactions with its
environment.
Now, one might think that programming
autonomy is an oxymoron would be a good
point, but I don't think it is.
If if the program I write and install my
robot imparts constitutive autonomy,
which is enable the robot to constitute
its own identity, and if it imparts
adaptivity, which enable the robot to
modify itself from its interactions with
the environment, then I think that the
robot will be truly autonomous.
Now, for autonomy to exist inherently in
the robot, something in the robot must be
at stake.
And in this case, it's the survival of
the robot society of mind.
Now, the physical structure of the robot
is not at stake.
Its survival is not at stake, unless, of
course, it falls off a shelf.
But as I intend to have my robot develop
its society of mind from experiences, I
also expect that if it fails, that this
society of mine will perish in its
attempt to grow and sustain itself.
So that's what's at stake going forward
in this project is the survival of the
robot society of mind.
This survival would be an expression of
being.
By doing, the robot will need to act and
interact in its environment in order to
survive.
Now, whatever sense it's going to make of
its environment will then be grounded in
this survival imperative.
In essence, the robot society of mine
will have skin in the game.
If this weren't the case, then sense
making would actually reside somewhere
else.
It would reside in in the mind of the
programmer, in my mind as I observe the
robots.
But I would like the sense making to be
grounded in the survival of the robot's
mind itself.
So that's key.
Now, what do I mean by an evolving and
growing society of mind?
So instead of the given society of mind,
which I showed earlier, I want the
cognition actors to be created to connect
with each other dynamically through
interactions with the environment.
So I want an active, self organizing,
self optimizing collective of cognition
actors.
Now, is this feasible?
Well, that's a big question.
In trying to answer this question, I'll
be also answering questions like what
must be given a priori and what can be
discovered?
Well, I already have elements of an
answer.
I know that the sensors and the effectors
and the primitive cognition actors that
wrap them will be given.
This will be like what you're born with,
basically.
And there might be a metacognition actor
which role will be to oversee and guide
the evolution of all other cognition
actors.
But that's my hypothesis.
I can imagine a test environment for my
robot that will test its ability to
survive.
I can imagine, for example, that as the
robot moves around or computes, it uses a
limited store of energy it's stimulated.
And that store of energy is replenished
when the robot consumes food.
And that would be by being on top of
pieces of paper, colored pieces of paper
on the floor.
And I'm going to make sure that it needs
two sources of food in order to survive.
That would be represented by a yellow
paper and a green paper, for example.
So that to prevent the robot from just
simply finding one source of food and
just stationing itself over it.
So the environment will also contain
obstacles.
So the robot will need to learn how to
navigate, avoid obstacles, locate
different sources of food, get to them,
and make sure that it alternate between
various sources of food in order to
survive.
And the society of mind that will evolve,
will hopefully evolve to successfully do
this.
Else if it doesn't, then it will shrink
as resources disappear and essentially
die.
So that's what it's at stake for this
robot.
Now, this effort employs a number of
frameworks, and by framework, I mean a
useful system of concept and constraints
that guide the implementation.
Well, there's obviously the free energy
principle and the Active inference
framework.
However, I see this, the Acactive
Inference, as an as if framework.
It describes the what what must be
achieved in this case, reduction of the
agents, variational, free energy.
But it doesn't guide me as to the
implementation, how to build the robot.
For this, I need as is frameworks.
And I'll be using two frameworks, one
which I've been using since the beginning
of the project, which is the Actor model.
.
The Actor model views computation as a
diversity of processes, processes that
are independent, have their own private
internal state, and who communicate with
one another strictly through messages.
Yesterday in Enterprise One, Keith Duggar
presented on the Actor model and made the
case that we should use the actor model
to implement active inference agents.
Well, I wholeheartedly agree with them.
The other framework that I'm going to be
using is a special case of symbolic AI
called the App Perception Engine.
And much of the presentation will be
about the App Perception Engine and its
implementation.
So here's where we are is the project is
located at the intersection of Active
Inference as a domain, the Wet and
Society of Mind as an architecture, and
symbolic AI as a form of computing.
So that's where the project is, at this
intersection.
So where to begin?
So I want to dive into a more extensive
form of learning.
And the first step, logically, is to
learn how to predict.
So I want to enable a single cognition
actor.
We'll start with a single cognition actor
to learn how to make sense of its local
environment, its so called unvelt.
And making sense implies, at a minimum,
to be able to predict incoming sensations.
.
So it needs to learn to predict.
So what will be given to a cognition
actor?
Well, there will be a history of
sensations broken into discrete units of
time.
So time n minus three and N minus two, n
minus one time n, which is the present
moment.
So these would be remembered observations.
.
And then what we want to get out of this
is the ability to predict the next
incoming set of sensations at time t
equals n plus one, n plus two.
And for this, to be able to predict
future observations, we need some kind of
predictor function that is learned from
the remembered observation.
Now, this predictive capability can be
built in two very general ways.
One is from statistics, so doing pattern
analysis and being able to predict what's
most probable, which is the standard
current machine learning approach.
Or we could predict from an understanding
of the observations by developing a
causal model of what produced these
sensations, and from this understanding,
predict what rationally should be
observed next.
So this is all about sense making.
And now what is sense making?
How do I understand sense making?
Well, to rationally predict incoming
sensory inputs, one must make sense of
them.
That's what making sense means to me.
And to make sense of sensory inputs means
to derive meaningful experiences from
them.
It's not just data, it's not just pieces
of data.
There must be meaningful experiences.
And by experience, I mean a
conceptualization of the sensations and a
unification of them in time and space.
So making sense of these inputs will mean
to produce meaningful experiences that
are conceptualizations and unifications
of the sensations.
Now, an experience is meaningful if it is
underwritten by a causal model.
So the experience is perceived as the
consequences of a latent generative model,
, generative process that we have modeled.
.
And I want meaning to be inherent to the
agent.
And that only happens if the agent is
truly autonomous and if this meaning is
grounded in the survival imperative, as
discussed earlier.
So how does experiencing work?
How can that be put into computer code?
Surprisingly for this, we refer to the
philosophy of Emmanuel Kant.
Emmanuel Kant took a reverse engineering
approach, asking himself what must
entities do to achieve experience?
This is akin to the free energy
principles high Road, which can be
paraphrased as what must organisms do to
maintain their existence?
So Emmanuel Kong tried to reverse
engineer cognition, asking himself what's
the minimal cognitive apparatus needed by
an entity to have experiences?
And that he documented in his critique of
pure reason.
Just a little parenthesis.
The meaning of the title Critique of Pure
Reason is not what I thought it was.
It actually translates more closely to
the case for April.
Cognition critique is a legal term is
where you make your case and pure reason
we translate nowadays.
April cognition.
So his work wanted to establish what must
happen to create an experience that's
coherent, that is unified in time and
space, and to reverse engineer cognition
as a system that is both complete and
essential, that is minimal.
Okay, so I'm going to try to give you the
postage stamp version of Emmanuel Kant's
theory focusing on the Synthetic Unity of
Apperception.
Well, first of all, there's the real
world, which is outside of our direct
experience.
It's the pneumonia.
It's forever hidden from us as an as is
reality, but it impinges on our sensorium.
.
And then so we have a number of
intuitions, sight, sound, touch, smell
that are initially separate, and then we
need to network them, connect them both
in time and in space.
In space is sound.
And the sight describing a single thing
is one thing behind or inside another.
And in time, is this happening before,
after something else?
And then at a higher level, meaning is
given to these networked, intuitions,
sensations via concepts and judgments,
rules which are generalizations as to
what can and cannot be.
And this is what we experience.
Now, it turns out that synthetic Unity of
Apperception is a blueprint for
automating sense making.
It's kind of interesting, I think, that
18th century philosophy would be relevant
to 21st century technology development.
And this is what happened and was
published by Richard Evans and all in the
paper Making Sense of Sensory Input,
where they developed the App Perception
Engine.
They took synthetic Unity of Apperception
as software requirements and successfully
implemented them into a piece of software,
, the App Perception Engine, and applied
it to a number of exercises where they
got a very good result.
So the App Session Engine is in an
instance of machine learning.
It's unsupervised machine learning, and
it operates on very small data sets and
generates human readable generative
models.
When I read the paper, I realized, well,
that's exactly what my robot needed.
So what does an app perception engine
do?
Well, given a sequence of observed states,
, it finds a generative model that can
recreate past states but most importantly,
, predict future states.
And the state is defined as a set of
simultaneous observations, sensations,
intuitions.
So an apperception engine searches for a
causal theory that can recreate
observations.
I say searches because this causal theory
is not determined by the observations.
It has to be found.
It has to be discovered.
But once it is found, then it can be
validated against the observations and
see if it can recreate them and augment
them into the future as well as into the
past.
So what is a causal theory?
A causal theory is a logic program that
has a number of components.
In the causal theory, there will be the
objects and the predicates from the
observed relations.
So from the observations, we can extract
what objects were observed and what
properties of these objects were observed
and maybe what relationships these
objects were observed.
That's the start.
Then we have latent object types, objects
and predicates.
So we may want to imagine causal theory,
imagines hidden objects, maybe hidden
types of objects and maybe hidden
properties and relationships between
objects, latent meaning unobserved.
And given both the observed and
unobserved objects and predicates, it
derives rules, first of all constraints
on those predicates, what's permissible.
So for example, being in front of A
cannot be in front of B and at the same
time behind B.
So an object cannot be in front of
another and behind it.
So there are constraints on predicates
and then there are rules that apply to
any simultaneous sets of observations,
what they must conform to.
Then there are rules that given a state,
will infer the next state and then maybe
some initial state from which we can run
the causal theory.
So what makes a causal theory unified?
Well, first of all it needs to be unified
in order to make sense of the observation.
.
There are various dimensions.
So if a causal theory involves a number
of objects, all these objects must be
directly or indirectly related.
There's no object that just floats in
space totally independent of the other
objects, so they must all be related.
So they're spatially unified.
All predicates that make up the causal
theory, like on, off, behind, in front,
they must be constrained so that, for
example, in front cannot be at the same
time as behind or that a light cannot be
both turned on and turned off.
So there's some restrictions on the
predicates and that creates conceptual
unity.
And then there's static unity where all
simultaneous relations must satisfy the
static rules, and temporal unity, where
all the states must be sequenced by
causal rules.
We'll see examples.
So let's start with an example here of a
set of observations.
What we are observing are two lights and
the lights can either be at any discrete
moment in time, either on or off.
So here we have a sequence of
observations and one moment in time.
The first light was off and the second
light was on.
Then the first light was on, the second
light was off, then both were on, et
cetera.
And I put the gray bars there to show
that maybe the observations are
incomplete.
So at one stage we can only see the
second light or there may be other lights
or other objects that we do not see, but
that's what we observe.
So you feed these observations in
discrete time into the apperception
engine and the perception engine searches
for a causal theory that when applied to
an initial condition, let's say that
light A is off and light B is on.
It will create a trace of recreated
observations.
That cover is a superset, matches the
initial observations.
And if this happens, then our causal
theory is a good one.
Now, the causal theory may infer the
existence of hidden objects, hidden
relations, and whatnot it may actually
need to.
So here's an example of a causal theory
that is generated by my own
implementation of the App perception
engine.
Because I re implemented the App
perception engine as described in the
paper by Richard Evans and all, and I ran
it on the set of observations about
lights on two lights, one on, one off at
any point in time.
And it came up with it found a result.
It found the result in 64 seconds.
It was a perfect match.
And it actually invented a relationship,
which it called thread One, which we can
let's imagine that it actually means
connects to.
And it found a static rule and a causal
rule.
It said that a light is on at any moment
in time.
A light is on if a light that connects to
it is off.
And it found a causal rule that said a
light turns off if it connects to another
light that was also off.
So that's how the lights change over time,
, the status of on and off.
And it came up with initial conditions
that said that, well, A connects to,
first of all, that there's an object one,
a light called object one that we don't
see, but is there, we imagine is there,
that A connects to it.
The light object one connects to B, and
the light B connects to object one.
So that's the causal rule that it
discovered.
Now, if we run this causal rule, we
produce a trace.
And as you can see, the trace matches the
observation.
It adds a new object.
So the coverage being excellent, being
perfect in this case, and our causal
theory is a good one.
It's actually a perfect one.
It's not necessarily the only one, though.
.
So is this causal theory unified?
So going back to Dr.
Kant's requirement of synthetic unity, of
Apperception, not every causal theory
will do, though it may predict correctly,
it may not be meaningful unless it is
unified.
Well, we saw the four dimensions of
unification.
Is it spatially unified?
Well, all our objects are connected
directly or indirectly to each other.
That's good.
So we have spatial unification.
Do we have conceptual unification?
So we have this new predicate.
We have two predicates, right?
Pred One, which we translate to, connects
to, and then the predicate that says
whether the light is on or off.
Well, we have a constraint that says that
a light can only be connected to one
other light.
So pred one has a constraint on it that
says it's exclusive.
So an object cannot pred one to two
objects cannot connect to two objects.
That's a constraint that was discovered
and part of the causal theory.
And also implicitly, the on relation of
the predicate has the value on or off,
and it cannot be both at the same time.
So it's conceptually unified.
Is it statically unified?
Are the static rules obeyed.
Well, for example, the static rule would
say that given that B connects to A, if B
is off, then A must be on.
So if you look at any place where B is
off, a is going to be on.
And you could do that for every other
light and relationships between lights.
So they all obey the static rule.
And the causal rule says, for example,
here, that if B connects to A, then if A
was off, then B must turn off.
So if you look at B, let's say B was off.
.
Yeah, I'm sorry, if B connects to A, and
yes, and if A was off, B must be off.
So if A was off, B becomes off the next
step.
So that's correct as well.
So statistically we are true, and
temporarily we are true.
We are unified.
And of course, that we get a thumbs up
from Dr.
Kant, our causal theory is unified.
Thus it makes sense of the observations
of the sensory inputs.
Now, it's no accident that Kant would be
would figure in an active inference
project.
There is a link between active inference
and Kant, and it runs through the
celebrated 19th century German engineer
Herman von Hemholz.
He was a disciple of Kant and he
developed the theory of visual perception
that operationalized Kant's epistemology.
.
And in fact, it anticipates predictive
processing.
In 1995, Peter Day and Jeff Hinton
developed the Helmholtz machine.
Name is in his hunter.
It is a type of artificial neural network
that's trained to create a generative
model from an original set of data.
And it can account for the hidden
structure of the data.
So as you see, there's a link which is
discussed and elaborated in this paper,
which is very interesting paper.
All right, so close parentheses.
So we've looked at the App Perception
engine from the perspective of philosophy.
.
So now let's look at it through the lens
of machine learning.
The observations constitute a training
set.
It's a very small one.
And the Appetition engine is the learning
algorithm.
And what is learned, the output is a
causal theory.
So the learning process is unsupervised
logical inferencing, and the output is a
human readable logic program.
So we see here that there's some profound
differences with the more popular form of
machine learning in that the training set
is really small, that the product of the
learning is actually a human readable
artifact, in this case, a logic program.
So this is the training set.
As inputted lights led, a turned off at
time one, b turned on at time one, a
turned on at time two, b turned off at
time two, et cetera, et cetera.
So that's the training set and you feed
this into the perception engine's
algorithm and out comes a causal theory.
So in a little bit more details what the
algorithm is and does.
First, it extracts the observed object
extent objects, the object types and
predicates from the observations.
So we have on, we have object A, object B.
.
We have led as an object type.
So that's all part of the observations
and that becomes part of the extent
vocabulary.
Then the application engine imagines
unobserved objects, types and predicates
for the relationships and properties, and
that becomes a latent vocabulary.
So there's a step of imagination.
Then, using the combined vocabulary, both
the extent and latent vocabulary combined,
, it looks for a unified causal theory, a
set of constraints, rules and initial
conditions that obey the constraints of
synthetic unity of apperception.
Once it has this causal theory and with
initial conditions, it applies the causal
theory to these conditions and produces a
trace.
It recreates observations if you want and
augments them and extends them into the
future.
Now it looks at this trace and compares
it with the initial observations for
coverage and decides if this is a good
causal theory or not.
Then it also looks at the causal theory
complexity, how many rules, how complex
are the rules, et cetera, and measures
for complexity.
So if we have a choice between two causal
theories of equivalent coverage, the App
Perception Engine will select the least
complex one using Occam's Razor.
Now, if you look at this algorithm, you'
'll see that the boxes in green are not
deterministic.
This is where search happens.
We can posit different kinds of objects.
We can find different kinds of rules.
So this is where search happens.
Now, app perception is implemented using
logic inference.
Actually, it uses three forms of logic
inference.
There's the one that we're more familiar
with, which is deduction, where given
rules and causes, we infer the effects.
Then there's induction.
Where given causes and effect, we look
for the rules.
This is what science does, right?
Looking for rules that would account for
effects given the causes.
Then there's abduction, where given the
rules and given what we observe the
effects, we're looking for the causes.
In this case, we're looking for the
latent objects, the latent relationships
between these objects.
And then you can combine both abduction
and induction, where you're given effects,
, essentially observations, and you're
looking for both causes and rules, which
is what the App Perception Engine does.
And this is where in the algorithm, these
kinds of inferences are at play.
So positing latent objects, that's a form
of abduction, imagining causes, finding
the rules, well, that's clearly a form of
induction.
And then applying the rules of a causal
theory to some initial conditions to
create a trace, well, that's deduction.
We have the causes, the initial
conditions, we have the rules, causal
theory, and then we produce a trace, the
effects.
So that's deduction.
So the App Perception Engine uses all
forms of logical inference.
Now, just a reminder that the output of
the App Perception Engine, that is what
is learned is actually human readable.
You may want to compare that to a large
array of floating points produced by
traditional, the more popular form.
Of machine learning nowadays.
So here, this is what's actually produced
by the app reception engine.
As it runs on a set of observations, it
produces a logic program that is human
readable.
When you look at it, the only thing you
need to kind of guess is what is meant by
pred one.
And if you think, well, maybe it means
connects to maybe the lights are
connected underneath a board out of sight
of the observer.
But finding a unified causal theory is
hard.
So we have to guess what the latent
objects and predicates are.
What are the hidden lights, what are the
hidden relationships between lights?
And we have to discover what constraints
might apply on the predicates and what
are the initial conditions from which we
want to recreate a trace.
What are the static rules that apply to
simultaneous observations?
And then what are the causal rules that
given observations at time T will predict
observations at time T plus one?
This is hard.
As a matter of fact, it's non
polynomially hard.
The search space grows exponentially with
the size of the input, which is the size
of the extent and latent vocabulary.
So just like in chess, you can't predict
to the end the consequence of a move
because of common turbo explosion.
With the app perception engine, you
cannot systematically traverse the entire
space of possible causal theories to find
a good one because it's impossibly large.
.
So the job of the apperception engine is
to find a causal theory in a ridiculously
large haystack.
How to do this?
In my implementation, I follow the
recommendations and I follow also the
implementation in Richard Evans'paper by
breaking the search space into chunks.
First there's a region and the region
says so how many latent object types,
objects and predicates will we allow?
So what is the limit of imagination of
the cognition actors that is trying to
apperceive a causal theory?
What are the limits of its imagination?
And within that region of bounded
imagination, we carve it into templates
where we say, okay, we're going to use
these latent objects types, these latent
objects.
And so basically, what vocabulary,
specific vocabulary we're going to be
using?
We're going to use object one.
We're going to use object pred one on top
of the observed on predicate and observed
A and B lights.
And we're going to set the maximum
complexity on the rules and see if we can
find causal theories that fit this
template.
So this is a carving up of the search
space and having broken the search space
into regions and templates, we have
scopes in which to apply Heuristics.
Now.
Why heuristics?
Because the systematic traversal cannot
be done in reasonable time.
There's just too many candidate causal
theories to look at to find a good one.
So we use Heuristics.
We find ways of maybe getting to a good
solution faster at the risk of missing it.
.
But at least we'll have an answer or no
answer in a reasonable amount of time.
And there's a number of heuristics that I'
've implemented in my implementation of
the app assetron engine.
Well, there's time boxing.
At some point, you'd spend no more than
this amount of time looking into a region
or into a template.
There's multitasking.
Well, the problem is actually, as they
say, embarrassingly parallel.
You can explore multiple regions and
multiple templates in parallel and so
make good use of a multicore computer.
You want to make sure you don't repeat
yourself.
So you don't want to traverse the same
region twice or look at the same causal
theory twice.
You want to satisfy maybe a good enough
theory is just fine.
We don't want to look for the perfect one
necessarily.
We may not have time.
You want to fail early.
If you're in a region where nothing good
is found, you may want to leave it quite
quickly at the risk of maybe not finding
a good one that is just over the horizon.
.
But you want to be impatient.
You want to throw the dice.
You may want to kind of mix it up so that
every time you run the app Perception
Engine on the same problem, you may find
a different solution first.
You want to go for the simpler solution
first.
You may not want to try everything, just
sample some.
You want to start with the easiest part
of the search base first, be judicious
and so forth and so on.
And most importantly, be selective.
So reject any causal theory that would
fail the constraints of unity of
apperception.
With all these in place, my
implementation of the app Perception
Engine gives pretty good results.
So here I did a run.
This is not cherry picked.
I decided to do one series of seven runs
and collect the data and show it.
And in this run, I set up the apparition
engine to only accept a perfect causal
theory, one that would produce a trace
that totally covers the observation.
And I did seven runs.
The first one succeeded, found it in 4
seconds.
The second one, it took 102 seconds.
So there's some randomization in the
order in which things have searched if
luck is involved.
As I said, the third one, 1 second, that
was pretty cool.
The fourth one, well, took 204 seconds,
then 90, 612, 99.
So quite a good distribution here.
Now, I said, okay, I'm going to run the
app Perception Engine again on the same
training set that I showed earlier, those
two lights.
But this time I said, I'm going to accept
the theory that has 85% or more coverage.
.
So it recreates the observations well
enough, but not perfectly.
And I time boxed it to 30 seconds.
So you have 30 seconds to find it.
Go.
The first run, it find a causal theory
with 75% accuracy immediately.
Then the same accuracy, same coverage.
10 seconds.
11 seconds.
It hit 29 seconds.
It found a perfect one.
Then eleven, it found 87% coverage and
stopped right there.
That's good enough.
75 again, 100% is the first one it found
above 85 in 18 seconds and 75% 0 second.
So a good distribution again, so we're
getting into reasonable times.
We're not talking about hours here, we're
talking about seconds.
And I'm hoping to do further
optimizations and bring it down to
something even smaller so that a
cognition actor can say, I want to make
sense of these observations, query the
apperception engine, and get an answer, a
causal theory within maybe a couple of
seconds.
That's my hope.
Now, something interesting here.
It so happens that what makes it hard for
the app perception engine to find a good
causal theory is formally equivalent to
what makes cognitive science as a whole
hard.
And this paper here makes the case and
proves the case quite cogently.
So cognizant science wants to find models,
, functions or algorithms that explain,
account for situated behaviors.
So you feed into the cognitive science
machine pairs of situations and behaviors,
, and you want to come out of it a model,
an explanation, a function, or an
algorithm that accounts for it.
Well, the paper makes the case that if
the explanation is to be bounded in size,
then the problem is computable, but it's
not tractable in the sense meaning that
it's combinatorially explosive.
But once you have a solution, it is
computable and tractable to verify that
the solution is good, that it accounts
for the data that you're trying to
understand.
Well, this is equivalent, formally
equivalent to what the app perception
engine is doing.
My implementation was done in prologue.
I will not go into the details.
It's about 1000 lines of prologue.
I'll just say that prologue is a
programming language that use deductive
inference as its model of computation
with backtracking.
So essentially it searches for a solution
and will backtrack if it took the wrong
branch if you want.
And we'll look for a different way of
satisfying a line of the program.
So let's just say that it makes
traversing a search space.
We get traversing a search brains for
free when we program in prologue.
I won't go into any more details, but you
can see some prologue code here.
And the fun thing is that a prologue
program is akin to a logical description
of the problem it's trying to solve.
I think it's very cool.
And prologue environment was augmented by
something called constraint handling
rules, which is an extension to prologue
that adds abductive reasoning.
So basically in the program, you can say,
assume this is true until proven
otherwise, and the CHR rules are there to
verify if it can be proven otherwise.
So, again, I'm not asking you to
understand this code at all, but I want
you to realize that this code is the code
that actually executes a causal theory,
both the static and causal rules to build
traces.
It is that small.
It's very powerful.
So combining prologue and CHR, I found
extraordinarily powerful.
I'm very excited about it.
I'm a programmer.
Next steps.
Well, next steps, now that we've solved
individual learning by cognitive actors,
well, I want to move to beliefs from
sensations and to policies to validate or
eliminate beliefs.
A lot of these beliefs actually fall out
of our perception.
Latent objects and latent relationships
and properties can be considered as
beliefs.
Then there are other kinds of beliefs
that can be obtained from what's been
perceived.
There will be introspective beliefs that
communicate how the cognition actor is
doing in terms of competence,
predictionary rates, how well its
apperception is doing, and whether it is
engaging with other cognition actors.
Is it relevant?
I will have feelings which will provide
normativity to these beliefs.
So if feelings are signals of risk to
homeostasis, loss of resources, physical
damage, too many prediction errors so
that's anger, pain, and fear and feelings
will taint beliefs over time and tainted
beliefs, good beliefs, bad beliefs will
want to be eliminated or validated
through policies that will be synthesized
by the cognition actor.
And each cognition actor will make
available to others its API.
What predictions can be made about the
beliefs of this cognition actor?
What actions are available to others to
be asked of the cognition actor?
And then as cognition actors connect to
one another, as the conjunction actors
form the umbelt of other cognition actors,
, then a conjunction actor will be able
to predict the beliefs of others, will be
able to compose policies made out of
actions that are implemented by other
cognition actors.
And eventually, we'll have a society of
mind, which is a bunch of intersecting
boom belts.
So that's it.
So I see the society of mine is a complex
system of collective theorizers.
And I'm going to try going further with
this project to answer the question if
collective theorizers can self organize
to actively sustain itself.
So thank you to the Active Inference
Institute for inviting me to present and
for providing a home for this project and
for the constant support and
encouragement.
I'll see you later on Discord.
Thank you.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you, JF.
Just to conclude the session, I'll read
two questions and let's maybe address
them in an upcoming Robotics and embodied
meeting.
So if you're excited about this project,
certainly we all are and about symbolic
active inference, join the Discord and
participate in the Robotics and Embodied.
.
But I'll drop these two questions from
David Williams in the Chat, who wrote,
one, how important is conducting this
work in real world versus simulation?
And two, what tools or components are
missing in the robotics toolkit to make
this research easier and better?
I know those are things that you have a
lot of thoughts on, so I'll look forward
to discussing with you more.
Thank you, JF.
JF: Thank you.
Daniel: Peace.
JF: All right.
Daniel: See you.